okay great thank you very much for this
kind introduction and thanks to all of
you for showing up because I mean I
gotta admit the stuff I'm talking about
is gonna be a bit a little bit less
sketchy than for instance training space
invaders with a neural network so I'm a
PhD student at the neural information
neural information processing group at
the 20 billion with professor Klaus
Obermeyer and usually I deal with the
simulations of neural networks but now
or today I'm going to talk about a
little Python toolkit I've been
developing on the side which is called a
pipette and so if you find yourself in a
situation like me that you deal with
systems that are highly parametrized so
for instance I simulate parts of the
brain or you do some machine learning
pipeline or develop a new machine
learning algorithm that has like tons of
hyper parameters then you have such a
highly parametrized system and sometimes
what you want to do is not just run it
once but with different parameter
settings so sample from this high
parameter space and then later on look
at the results and analyze analyze them
like very currently and so if if this
summer applies to you then this tool can
help you in in doing this so but let me
first start out with sort of the
motivation here why i came across
developing this python application so
let's say this is the ideal circle of
numerical experiments or simulations or
if you if you start prototyping some
application so basically you start out
with an rough idea or hypotheses about
what your model is about or what it
should do and then after like good
planning a hat you start implementing
your model you start coding and once
it's done you of course run your model
you gather some results in your
simulations and this helps you to refine
your idea and see if your hypothesis
actually works out and then with this
you can again improve your coding run
new simulations and basically go in the
circle over
over again until I don't know like a
scientific publication pops out or you
have a super cool machine learning
application and the only problem is that
is a very idealized world because the if
you look at the ground truth here so you
start with an idea it's like yeah let's
let's just hack something together so
let's just get it running quick and
dirty and of course I need to run my
system with different parameter settings
so okay I got my python script here so I
got to start it again and again with the
different settings so the simplest thing
I can do for instance do some bash
scripts that restart my pipe next
executive little quite some some some
time and of course this turns out some
some results or data which I somehow
need to see realize and store to disk
for instance using pickle and then you
end up with I don't know like hundreds
or thousands of files which you later on
need to analyze so you write some other
heck eio that somehow reads the data and
you can then make some some nice map
lovely plots with it and see if your
idea worked out and maybe not so you
write some more spaghetti code and you
go in this circle this works fairly well
as long as you go forward that's because
at some point you might realize okay
there was there were some ideas in the
past maybe two months ago which weren't
actually so bad so maybe I should look
back at three simulations or results I
gather two months ago and if you go in
this circle and using ok maybe maybe
let's repeat an old simulation you might
miserably fail and yes in the worst-case
scenario you're not even having your
source code under git version-control so
this is really doomed to fail yeah
you're laughing now but if you talk to
if you talk to scientists there's an
awful many of them like who haven't
heard about get yet at all so and
they're versioning is like my math lab
file version one my Motlop file version
to my matlab file version 2.1 from
yesterday or something like that and so
if you if you if you go around this and
you try to repeat in all simulation this
this doesn't work so it's kind of sad
it's also getting worse if someone else
it's like a colleague of Europe comes
along and tries to understand what you
did here because he thinks we got some
some neat ideas in the first place the
only problem is so this this is hard to
tackle then for him to actually
understand what you did so this is where
my tool kit comes into play you see
everyone's happy so so pipette basically
tackles the both points down here so the
parameter expiration bash scripts that
are no longer needed we're like nested
for loops in your outer main script and
also it provides some some IO
functionality that automatically stores
your data so I mean if you write back
code spaghetti code no one can read this
is still your own problem so okay so
what does pipat stand for it so it's
sense for Python parameter expiration
toolbox and as I said it's suitable for
any sort of numerical simulation that
you run in Python or at least start with
a Python script and so as I said so the
main objectives of this toolkit are a
easy exploration of highly parameterised
spaces or models with a high parameter
space and easy storage and retrieval of
the computer results and the underlying
set of parameters so tight linkage
between the parameters you used to run
your model whatever it is a brain
simulation a machine joining pipeline so
that these parameters you use to obtain
your results your your accuracy or your
time series data this is like tightly
linked and can always see okay this was
the set of parameters I used together
this numerical data okay so how does it
work so it evolves around a new Python
container so which is called trajectory
so it's basically a more sophisticated
dictionary or to be precisely like a
nested dictionary because it implements
sort of a tree data structure and it
manages all your parameters and results
so for instance we have this function
here f at parameter so this this prefix
f here I stole the idea from PI tables
that these functions of these containers
that actually do something for you start
with an f underscore so you can actually
distinguish them from data you put in
there so for instance we could add a
parameter here
I give it a name like traffic n cars so
this is the name of the parameter and
this is a particular group and so for
instance it's the number of cars in a
traffic simulation so we give it a
default value and you can always provide
a common so that other people understand
the scope of your parameter we could add
another parameter that belongs to the
very same group and it's a number of
cyclists you give it a default value you
can add a comment and we might have for
instance some some more major parameters
like a step size of your numerical
integration system or whatever and yeah
when you do that of course you can
recall the data because this is a
container for all your parameters so
eventually in your simulations you need
them to actually do stuff with them so
for instance you can then recall the
data you just put in by this dot
notation so you can just say like trade
or traffic draw 10 cars and it just
gives you back like the the value we put
in there and so as user you're
encouraged to actually fine grain and
sort your parameters as fine as you can
as fine as you can as fine as possible
but in order to save your son typing so
you can you can skip intermediate hops
in this tree so you could say for
instance trade or cyclist and this will
initiate a very fast lookup if this is a
unique identifier and you get just
immediately back the the value of this
parameter so it's it's rather permissive
of stuff it swallows so the thing can
handle all sorts of Python natives of
course pool rule in float Python
containers and also likes numpy areas
matrices side by sparse matrices pandas
data frames and series and panels of
course if you are into computational
neuroscience you might have heard about
a simulator called brain Brian so it
also likes quantities and monitors of
the software thing and in brackets here
basically you can chuck everything in
there that you can pickle but I put that
in brackets here because if you do that
then you don't have any chance to
eyeball the data because reading pickle
strings is not nice and yeah and if you
work with anything else
and so there's a very simple API that
you can just extend and make it work
with with data that you have so as I
said the other objective here of this
trajectory is to allow arbitrary
explorations of the parameter space and
and this is why this container is called
trajectory but because it doesn't hold
just a single parameter value but you
can give it like a whole trajectory
through the parameter space that defines
on how you run your model and it's you
can you can do some some arbitrary
explorations so because we had for
instance our two parameters number of
cards the number of cyclists and you try
to explore your space like this like
this simple Cartesian product space or a
line were whatever comes to your mind
and as I said another objective pipette
was to store the data right at hand so
you know you don't have to touch the i/o
and currently so everything is chuck
into such a trajectory container is
automatically stored to disk and the
current back end is hdf5 I guess some
people have you have heard about hdf5 so
it stands for the hierarchical data
format version 5 which is a very neat
file format because it it can store
massive amounts of data it can read and
write pretty quickly and still it's
human readable and and so if you if you
for instance look in such a file you can
see here there's this file and folder
structure with these leaf nodes and you
can click on them and immediately
eyeball your data which for prototyping
and scientific applications is usually
very useful if you can immediately see
if the values kind of fit of your
expectations or if you already have a
box somewhere that already pops up by
some numbers that can't be true anyway
yeah so in order to interface hdf5
pipette uses the super grade pie tables
library and okay so this is the basic
data container that's provided by
pipette this trajectory there's another
object you can interact with and this is
called an environment and this is
basically a
Python object that helps you to
disentangle your core scientific or
prototyping simulation from from the IO
management and the execution so for
instance it does stuff like it manages
creating lock files for you it nicely
integrates with get so if your code base
under get version control what it will
do is it will either complain if you try
to run a simulation with a new code that
hasn't been committed yet or if you wish
it will just start an automatic git
commit for you and add the comments to
your trajectory as your gets comment and
also you can do you don't have to
specify the way you want to explore your
parameter space in advance so you can
also do some adaptive exploration and if
you have some search heuristic you can
combine it easily with pipettes or for
instance if you know the deep library
you can do use evolutionary algorithms
for instance to search the space and
also it natively supports
multiprocessing because it's basically I
mean you run a couple of simulations and
parallel us a couple of simulations that
are independent so it's clear that this
is super easy to paralyze so natively it
supports multi processing on a single
machine but if you combine it with the
cool scoop library you can also use that
on a cluster like an Sun growth engine
for instance and just let me show you a
quick live demo although you always told
not to do that okay so let's say we have
some particular task or simulation at
hand that we want to do and here let's
do something very simple and so let's
just say we simulate the multiplication
of two numbers it's it's fairly easy
task but I think it serves as a
straightforward example so let's say we
value Z and our our top level simulation
function here does take this new
container trajectory and we can of
course success everything by dot
notation so we can say our new value Z
is equal to trade out x times trade out
why yeah and of course we want to store
the results
and edits also to the trajectory so we
have to say tray please give me a result
or add the result under the name z with
the value Z and and that's about it so
this would be so usually you would do
something more sophisticated here I
don't know like a neural network
simulation as I said or super cool
machine learning but here let's just
multiply two numbers so and the only
thing now still missing is some
boilerplate code that actually runs our
simulation so we can say please pipe at
give me one of these nice environments
so we have to create that one and this
one will autumn trajectory for us and
now we still need to fill the trajectory
with the actual parameters so we can say
please add the following parameters so
we can stay x give it a default value
and maybe provide a comment so this is
the first dimension and also we have a
second one which is why and now we
specify that we have two parameters with
default value zero but we're actually
interested in exploring the space or
what happens if you multiply two numbers
what happens if you multiply for time
three for instance and not just 0 x 0 so
we can tell here simply in advance sorry
simply in advance how we want to explore
the space it's pretty simply just pass
this container with this function f
explore a dictionary of lists which just
gives you the way you want to explore
the space so for instance we choose X
should be 1 2 3 4 and why should be
let's say three three three and four and
so this will explore as just a these
four points 1 32 33 3 and 0 for 4 and so
if you had for instance the Cartesian
product in mind there are help of
functions that can provide you with a
Cartesian product but let's stick to
this simple example here so in the end
the only thing we still need to do is
tell the environment
that with this trajectory we want to run
our particular simulation which is
multiply and now this should run and
their finish pretty quickly and yawns
because we just multiplied four numbers
but if we now look at the file system so
we have a hdf5 file here which we can
look at then and it's a bit blurry and
increase that okay but um so I'm sorry I
can zoom in here right now but as you
can see so we got this four runs here
and for instance the last one I think
was four times four and luckily that's
16 so worked I'm that so ok you can do
live demos and okay so and usually what
you then would do is later on when you
gather your route raw data from your
simulation sees you would fire up the
thing again and then use this trajectory
container to load data from disk and
then do your analysis or plotting or
statistics or whatever you have in mind
and and so what is even more important
about pipe ads so its of course it's
open source it's available on github
it's available in pi PI it's fully
documented on read the docs and of
course it's it's thoroughly tested so
using Travis CI up there and I can
probably say over ninety percent code
coverage with more than a thousand tests
so it's already quite mature and that's
that's about it thanks this oh yeah so
sorry where to get pipette so as I said
it's not only available in github it's
also available on the Python package
index so you can simply pip install it
and it's pure python so if you have all
the prerequisites which are only a few
numpy syfy pandas and pie tables then
you're good and you shouldn't have to do
anything and this should finish within a
millisecond so okay the documentation is
online available there's a very
comprehensive tutorial and also many
many examples so if you're not the type
of guy who likes to read manuals it's
fine there's tons of examples how to use
it and and now that's almost about it
there's some some more bonus tracks so
I'm actually
at the end of my PhD and now I'm looking
for a job so I just like bluntly use
that situation to advertise myself and
so I'm I'm looking for a job as a data
scientist because usually I do this so I
stare at a bunch of differential
equations and try to solve them and cry
and then just numerically integrate them
but I would love to do apart from that
Python coding data science or machine
learning so thank you very much thanks
for your attention and so thank you for
you by nice talk and also for being so
courageous to start a life demo without
any code wouldn't before that's
impressive and yeah so we have plenty of
time for questions who has a question
over there is first do I have anyone to
do this no so thank you for doing that
because i guess i'm going to use it is
very useful and could you elaborate a
bit about the structure in your
trajectory how you relate the the
trajectory of the parameter space to the
datasets and so you mean so you you
explore the space and you create some
data and so so how you how do you do
just store like o KF z equals 2 as a
feature for my for my simulation and I
just have this new attribute or how do
you manage that and so the parameters in
hdf5 are actually stored as a as a huge
vector in there so an array just an HD
my favorite so but the results are
actually stored as as single leaves
because you're not supposed to have so
you don't have to have the same result
in our same type of result in every
simulation run because it might be that
you figure out during the run time that
something diverges so you cannot
immediately skip and you don't have to
store anything thank you
what questions yes so you would talk
about having more sophisticated
strategies for exploiting the search
space besides or lists so is it possible
to have this dynamically during runtime
like the basic approach we are
officially and so the the function
optimization itself is not in there so
if you have your own like Biogen
framework that just takes some results
and and produces i don't know like a new
probability distribution that you want
to sample then you can stick that in
there you can also already start
analyzing your data while they're still
runs in the background so you could for
instance i don't know like you have
already started out with 20 different
runs and why the last 10 are still
executing you review you throw up you're
patient framework you calculated your
probability distribution and i don't
know like draw 20 new runs and you just
add them to the year to the running
queue and there will be executed
eventually and you could still then in
an interval of reynolds like in the next
hour redo that while they're still runs
executing so and so as I said the
function optimization itself snot in
there but you can just plug it in and do
the analysis during runtime and increase
the run so this is for instance if you
have this evolutionary a toolbox deep
there are examples how you can just plug
in deep and let it do some search for
you
to go first we have time for both
questions so you already mentioned that
if something diverges you can just skip
the result I'm dealing with simulations
that go for a very long time do you have
any kind of crash management so for
example first power outage is there as a
possibility to create a log file and
like pick up from this point in later
time actually there is so so you could
so as long as everything that you have
can be handled by a library that's
called dil which is a bit more
sophisticated pickling then it can take
intermediate snapshots and you can pick
up from somewhere where somebody pulled
the power plug hi do you think it'll be
feasible to use just a parameter
exploration space with other [ __ ]
dueling back end with and yeah I I guess
so actually regarding backends so I'm
now also experimenting because some
people are not that happy with hdf5 so
that you also could for instance use
MongoDB and I was also someone suggested
using elastic search in the back end
which then would make the distribution
even more easier but yeah you could so
you could use the trajectory container
for instance completely independent of
this environment thing yeah I meant more
like Schilling back in like instead of
grid engine maybe spark or sing or
something like that so far there's only
the great engine supported and
multiprocessing but you're happy to
agree on I take contributions implement
that make a pull request great effect
just one very small question it's more
like a feature request one problem which
you see is is that the [ __ ] is this a
heavy duty core simulation function has
to know of trajectories I think it would
be rather nice to have a helper function
or a decorator which you can just plug
into a non non pipette error function
and just type edify doesn't make sense
or yeah it makes sense so I actually
thought about this having sort of like a
general decorator that you just like
attached to your function
and so I love decorators when they are
part of like a given library but having
the user reporting decorators and so
there are examples how you can wrap
around Python around an existing
simulation framework where you write
your own wrapper function I mean this
this is going to be like two or three
lines of code so you could do that in a
decorator but I think then it's hard to
understand how it works the magic behind
that okay um more questions or well if
not then let's thank our speaker again